in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 13th, on which we commemorate the synaxis of
the Holy Archangel, Gabriel, on the same day the memory of our venerable Father, Stephen,
the Sabahite.
Our Holy Father, Stephen, was born in about the year 725, in the village of Al-Jullis, in
the Ascolon region.
Being completely orphaned at the age of nine, he was taken by his uncle Zacharias, a monk
living near the Lavra of St. Sabahs, who brought him up in love for the highest Evangelical
virtues.
Stephen received the angelic habit at the hands of Zacharias.
He did not leave him for fifteen years, obeying him in all things as though he were Christ
himself.
When Zacharias left the Lavra to become avid of the monastery of the Castellon and of
the cave, a position he filled only for a short time before his death.
Stephen then fulfilled various obedience with unvering renunciation, baker for two years,
guestmaster for three.
Then, after being ordained deacon, he was canonarch in the liturgical offices.
He retired to his cell, being charged with the Lavra's library.
He lived thus for five years, spending all his time in prayer, and when he went down
to the church to join the community on Saturdays and Sundays, the monks hastened to greet him
with reverence, believing that they saw in him an angel of God come down from heaven.
Distressed by these signs of honor and warned of the dangers of Vanglory, he begged the avid's
blessing to withdraw into solitude.
But the latter refused.
After some time encountering the same difficulties, Stephen had recourse to patriarch Theodore of
Jerusalem, declaring to him that if he did not give him his blessing to live in solitude,
he would go off to a distant land.
Following the authenticity of his desire for God, the patriarch wrote to the avid, asking
him to let Stephen live in Hisikia until Easter.
Stephen then aged thirty-two settled in an ancient hermitage, some way south of the Lavra,
and lived there in prayer, assaulted by the demons.
From the feast of Saint Antony to great Thursday, on returning to the monastery for the celebration
of Great Week, he was greatly affected at seeing the monks pay him even greater respect
and honor, and he returned to the hermitage without delay, assailed by a horde of demons
that suggested to him that he temper his esquices and even tried to crush him under a rock.
He spent the rest of his days in this hermitage, persevering in constant prayer and only working
with his hands, rope-making, to drive away Asidia.
Three times a year he hid himself in the desert over towards the dead sea for a forty-day
retreat, in imitation of Saint Athemios, and some of the earlier fathers, only taking with him the
clothes on his back, a small axe for cutting the desert grass that he used for food, and a staff
topped by an iron cross. When he was in his hermitage, he avoided all contact with others,
except those who came to consult him for the salvation of their souls.
Standing constantly before God gathered deep within himself in a contrite spirit,
he valiantly resisted all the assaults of the spirits of darkness, and drew from this a profound
experience of spiritual combat. Weekend by perpetual fasting, he made countless frustrations
until he fell exhausted to the ground. One day when he had reached such a state of exhaustion,
he was carried in a vision beyond his human nature and filled with spiritual joy.
From that time he resumed his struggles with no thought for the weakness of the flesh.
After fifteen years he agreed to receive a few disciples whom he settled in a hermitage a little
way away from his own, and when he withdrew to the desert he took some of them with him.
He directed them wisely, discerning their secret thoughts, even when they were away from him,
and encouraged them in the struggle against the demons. When he reached the age of 53 in the year
778, a tested monk from Jarasa, called Martidius, who had long been seeking a monk who had attained
the fullness of virtue, came to him. Stephen gave him a hermitage near the one where St. John
the Hesse cast had lived, and often visited him to speak together about spiritual things.
It was on the advice of Martidius that he renounced his desire to withdraw into the deep desert
and become willing to receive visitors when he was in his hermitage. Having been ordained
priest, he was celebrating the divine liturgy one day in the hermitage chapel. When he came to the
words thine of thion, the grace of the Holy Spirit descended and covered the holy table in indescribable
light, the saint himself being light-filled. Seeing himself thus transfigured by the light of God
and being seized with fear at his unworthiness, he raised a prayer asking the Lord to restrain the
streams of his grace a little in this life, to give them an abundance in the other world.
God heard his request, but from that day forward, when Stephen stood before the holy table,
he received divine revelations and answers to all the problems brought by his visitors.
On one occasion during a retreat in the desert, along with several monks, they stopped at nightfall
near the bank of the Jordan. Having left his companions to sleep, Stephen got up, crossed to the
other bank, walking on the water, and stood in prayer the whole night, his arms raised to heaven
like two torches spreading light. Having achieved blessed impossibility through his ascetic struggles
and his tears, God gave him the gift of insight in such measure that he could discern the secrets
of all who went to him and unerringly predicted future events. He also received the power to act
miraculously on the course of events for the good of his brethren. In this way, he drove off by his
prayers the demon of a cruelly possessed young girl, and also, like Moses, made a spring bubble up
from dry ground by smiting it with his staff to give drink to his disciples who were exhausted from
thirst. God several times made him invisible, allowing him to pass unseen among bandits or threatening
bedwins. He showed his compassion and charity not only towards monks and visitors, but also to
animals in the desert, birds and insects which came to him to be fed by his hand, and he rebuked
his disciples when they crushed the earthworms outside his hermitage with their feet. One day
when his disciple and biographer Leontius had been assailed by blasphemous thoughts, he went to the
elder, ashamed at confessing such a sin. The saint told him to place his hand on his neck, and
solemnly declared to him that he would himself answer before God's judgment seat for this sin
incited by the demon. After having prayer all night for him, his disciple was definitively freed
from this type of temptation. During the last ten years of his life, St. Stephen took several
tested monks from the Lavra with him on his desert retreats. When he returned to his hermitage,
especially at the times of the great feasts, the faithful hastened from all sides to beg for his
prayers or his inspired words, and they departed with joy, filled with grace, spreading the word of his
fame, and confirming that even in those times of Muslim oppression, God had not taken his grace away
from his people. After having worked a great many miracles, St. Stephen fell asleep in peace,
following his own prediction on the 31st of March in the year 794, with the words of the Eucharistic
Anaphora on his lips. He was buried beside the relics of St. John the Hesse cast, through the prayers of
our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.